we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here is a
voicemail to wrap up the year so riddled
with crazy that i don't even know where
to start take a listen
eddie Proclus house you and perfect
clinton lovers and the black muslim
obama lovers you know i say you're gonna
start a civil war you people pick on
trump it's gonna win unanimously a
second term close he doesn't have a
teeth that's why she does isn't going to
bring the articles over to the senate
also but you know you pick on everything
if it was obama the muslim or crooked
Clinton or Biden you don't say anything
about him don't criticize them York
they're perfect they're Jesus
reincarnated you know why don't you pick
on Melania next what face will kind of
Kampong does she use and what about the
student works and barons Katie
weight-loss you people are idiots
you know you're a communist and plain
English and the capitalism is gonna win
and you know why don't you go back to
South America where you came from you
well where's your little buddy patty
he's not satisfying your with them
anymore right so listen we're used to
the homophobia we're used to all of that
stuff I've heard go back to South
America many times remember I am a
citizen of the United States but also
you know that we don't criticize
Democrats we've heard a sighs Democrats
all the time and in fact I was just I
was just criticized myself for being
critical of the way that some Democrats
are couching certain political issues I
love that he says Trump's going to win
unanimously I don't know that they know
that this person knows what that means
does the unanimous mean that Trump's
gonna win every state is Trump going to
win every vote what does that mean
unanimously and then again this idea
that I'm a communist first of all that's
not true and secondly the idea that the
threat is from communism in the United
States is laughable there is no threat
from communism in the sense that there
is no clamoring to turn the United
States into a communist a state
reminiscent of others that we have seen
in history so this is who we're fighting
since this is the last voicemail of 2019
here's my message that I attached to it
we can't convince those people to see
reason and come to our side so let's not
try let's not waste our time 2020 starts
tomorrow let's focus on finding the half
of the country that doesn't vote and
getting the people that already agree
with us to understand the importance of
getting out and casting a ballot in 2020
that's it for today Pat's got the bonus
show today I will be back with you on
January 2nd to kick off the David Pakman
show 2020